committee
um
we have apologies from councilors
Stewart Bond and kit
and somebody like to move that they're
accepted council's manager and Reverend
cook
put that all in favor
aye aye against carried one slight
change in the uh agenda uh normally
um item seven the youth Council report
is dealt with at the beginning but it
slipped down so we're going to bring it
back up to the top
so with that Levi and Ryan if you'd like
to come up and and take a seat welcome
along to the meeting this is your
inaugural report of this youth Council
to
this committee welcome along thank you
for taking the time to join us this
afternoon thank you councilor Ludlow
um on behalf of the youth Council I just
uh like to say uh thank you to council
for having us here today and um yeah my
name is Ryan for those who've uh who've
not uh seen me here before and uh this
is Levi
hi
um so I take a report as a read
um we're just going to jump straight
into some of the feedback we have around
voting
um is we are with it in August I believe
that the council has to make a decision
regarding
um the voting structure for uh the next
local elections
um
and the two topics of discussion are uh
is TV voting uh versus first past post
as well as potentially lowering
um devoting age to 16 for local
elections both which um
news Council has some interest in
discussing
um
at the beginning of I would just like to
uh say for this year uh we've got for
our 40 persons uh our uh Hannah and
Lydia uh the two cheap persons we've got
two deputies Katie and Tiffany however
neither of them were able to make it
today
um so
uh now he's TV
um
Levi if you just want to add something
oh okay so uh yeah the youth Council uh
widely agrees that uh we should switch
to a single transferable vote system
um and we all know what that is or
should I give like a brief explanation
no you don't need to if counselors don't
know by now they're going to find out
yeah I'm sure
yeah so uh General consensus was that we
support uh transferred to STV voting and
the reason being is that typically it
seems like it will provide a more
effective representation all around just
given the nature of council elections
um specifically
there's been some discussion and I
personally think
uh it could not maybe me more effective
to have it for the East TV for the
position of me rather than as just all
counselors but I mean if you wanted to
keep consistency you could do both
um but we just thought it would help
provide better representation uh as a
whole
um typically
um those who want is TV voting
um you know they're not getting the
representation they quite want with
first pass post but those who don't
really have much of an opinion on the
matter or prefer to uh vote first pass
post
um don't really mind I think it doesn't
affect them a lot if you understand what
um
your perspective on that the the benefit
there is with STV you can vote for as
many or as few candidates as you'd like
um and you can use this as a first
classified system if you so please
um for like however many people
um and your order of preference
um what's good about it is the diversity
it can bring
um when we have STV everyone can rank
their preferences and
no matter what you're sort of guaranteed
to have somebody that you like elected
based on how it goes
what's the What proportion of the youth
Council supported is TV well let me ask
an easier question was there anyone at
youth Council who supported fpp uh no we
ran a poll um not everyone has answered
but we did see that all of them who
voted voter piece TV
yes
yeah
um okay so are there any questions on
that specifically radio questions around
TV and then we'll go around
all right when I'm talking oh sorry
thanks Tom uh
my question
was you use the word better
representation I think well you did use
the word beta I think there's bare
representation
would come from STV and I wonder if you
define better for me a little bit
um
I would define beta as more people
um in invercargill satisfied with who
um holds position in Council
so it would be hard to quantify
um in terms of like you know just asking
people I I suppose if that they are more
satisfied with the outcome of the
election rather than not
okay I just wonderful you know better
sort of implies the representation would
be better I think maybe what you're
meaning is fairer would that be yes yes
I think
it would be better in the sense that the
people of invercargill would be more
satisfied uh with the election system
um
okay okay thank you councilor Craig
councilor Ludlow
um just expanding on that with um what
councilor Campbell has said do you think
that with when you say more satisfied
through the STV system it's likely that
we would see more
um and perhaps when you're saying beta
is it more an accurate representation or
reflection of our diverse communities
and
ranges of people
you said it would be a more accurate
representation of who the people of
invercargill want aren't Council because
obviously with the first pass the post
system
um you're not really telling us who you
who you like so if well when you're
voting you say you like these people but
you can't distinguish
whether or not say none of them are
popular
uh that you'd rather this person over
this person if none of these people
didn't yeah so
councilman pottinger no I'll hold that
one right thank you
affects everything on that issue we'll
just uh talk about
um lowering the voting age so youth
Council does not have a consensus
opinion on whether we should we think
the voting age uh should be lowered to
16 uh for local elections
um so we're just going to give our
independent sort of opinions on what we
think as to use of invercargill
um
but first oh I can go first uh it's for
myself I am
uh absolutely opposed uh to the idea uh
that we should lower the voting age to
16th
um my opinion is primarily predicated on
the belief that I do not believe under
uh under 18 year old have sufficient uh
responsibility to uphold
um that right voting is and we so often
just say you know but it's you know it's
a right to be able to vote and have
representation well with that right also
comes responsibility in my opinion
um I think to have responsibility you
need to be look after yourself first and
foremost there are some you know there
are some people of course some
exceptions is always of um 16 17 year
olds who are independent and look after
themselves but many still live at home
um so not only do they look at not look
after themselves if you typically
wouldn't have a spouse or any dependence
that they also look after so I don't
think that they have the response
possibility that is required to elect a
body that also has responsibility for a
large number of people also you can make
the argument that you know typically
those under 18 don't have a great deal
of experience
um and it's questionable whether or not
they're able to make uh uniformed such
an informed opinion some people will
um just like some over 18 will not be
able to make an informed opinion or may
not have responsibility but I just think
there's more people at 18 and it also
keeps them consistent with our laws
regarding uh the drinking age when
you know if you were to get a home loan
for example all things which require you
to be 18.
because that's the age where typically
you'd have more responsibility and be
able to
make that decision
um
in a well thought out manner
although you can have children and get
married
not without your parents permission
though if you're under I believe anyway
I think if you're under 18 you need to
get um your parents permission to get
married between 16 30 minutes I'm not
100 sure
[Music]
I'm advocating for lowering the voting
age from 18 to 16. uh I've sort of
prepared a speech so
um yeah
um so yeah with a few points to explain
why it's necessary and beneficial
um I think the argument against lowering
the voting age
um is sort of only based on assumptions
like 16 year olds are too immature or
will vote at random in these elections
but you simply can't assume that 16 and
17 year olds aren't capable of making
educated proper decisions and yeah nor
can you assume that every voter over 18
is capable of making informed decisions
but you also can't discern what is an
immature or random decision uh unless a
voter admits to it
um there is also no evidence to say that
16 year olds are less responsible or
reliable than other voters
um
the maturity points kind of null and
void there um and how do we suddenly
trust them once they turn 18.
the problem everyone has with it is a
lack of trust like a fear of change
um and it's not very fair on the
underrepresented age group
working 16 year olds contribute to the
city they help to uphold it through the
labor they provide yet they are not
given the chance to participate and
deciding which people will make major
decisions for the city for them
even when decisions like how our public
Transporters managed for example can
directly impact their daily life or
their ability to work
by disallowing them to have this you're
only encouraging them to have empathy
towards voting
if these people are expected to act as
responsible members of society how come
we don't let them get their opinion like
other contributing citizens
some countries in Europe have already
made this change as 16 and 17 year olds
have the same criminal responsibility as
adults similar to what we have with 17
year olds in this country
and that people of this age are on the
verge of full Independence they are
planning for their futures uh this
change has seen significant positive
results and that the 16 to 17 age group
had a 19 voter turnout and a National
Council election in Austria
uh and that they were engaging with
politics
we trust and expect this age group to do
many things to drive safely to work to
be good citizens uh to handle our money
at supermarkets to behave appropriately
even when they are such important
contributors they don't have a way for
their say to be truly represented how is
this fair for no good reason are we not
trusting them
there are a few important benefits to
allowing this age group to vote
it encourages them to be more
politically active and to learn about
how everything works from a basic
starting point with local government it
provides a reason to look into
candidates and to inform themselves on
the fast-changing political landscape
and makes voting a familiar process and
encourages the likelihood that they will
vote in future elections
lowering the voting age will also
increase their sense of responsibility
and give them a sense of ownership with
the city which may encourage them to
find out about more important important
local issues
and it will likely dissect them from
things like graffiti since they feel
they are valued by the city
uh all in all the decision to lower the
voting age is not just about politics uh
it's about fairness in respect for the
voices of our youth by making this
change we will show that we value all
who contribute to our society
and that we want everyone's voices to be
heard thanks
for sharing your opinions guys it's
worth noting that you need to share
those with members of parliament who
ultimately are the ones
thank you chair yeah I guess my question
is that I'm sort of open-minded on it
but obviously it's a sign of being an
adult
um when you are allowed to vote at 18
and with that comes the ability
uh to serve in the military so obviously
would you see that being dropped 16 and
the key one is being tried in court as
an adult
for for crimes committed you which is
slightly different for 16 year olds at
the moment so do you see if you did drop
the burning age those other things would
fall into line tried as an adult and
being able to serve in the military I do
see things like that happening because
it's only fair right um same with things
like 16 year olds being able to run for
Council
um I say yes you can like you can leave
school at that point if you have the
means to if you have the time and the
ability then why not why don't we let
them
you'll miss a fair bit of class time
I'm involved in education and you're an
episode of creators to come here and
present like that well done thank you
any other questions counselors May Clark
just a couple of things cheers
um
uh Ryan you did really well to push back
on uh Darren on there not many people
get some ground over him so that was
really good
um just one general question
um last year when we had a first pass to
post election
um I fronted up with seven other
candidates as a mineral Forum with the
invercargill young professionals Group
which you would have thought was a a
group slightly older than you guys
um but have a professional Focus I think
there was eight of us there and eight of
them
so that in some ways gives me a bit of a
message that young people are not
necessarily into this this space anymore
it's in sports life development
getting a house sorted out relationships
jobs and other things so just an
interest in your view on that
um yes I I would agree with the
statement that I
some people are
um just the same uh in general elections
is always the exception but I think it
is for you to say that most people are
not they're engaged that's something
that you want to do more I wouldn't see
that necessarily though Happening by
lowering the voting age
um
you know I wouldn't
I don't see participation
um if we would love the voting age being
very significant and your view on the um
disparity between local government and
general elections
it's very low yeah youth participation
in general elections quite like that
would be even lower in local body
elections
which the amount of participation that I
don't think is an argument for why you
should or shouldn't lower or have
changed the voting age but um
yes it is something to note I guess I
was alluding to the general elections
being 18 years not 16 so it's a little
bit like saying you can you can drive a
car down one street you can't drive it
down another Street
um it's a little bit like saying you can
vote on local elections but you can't
lock both on the general election yeah
no I think it is important to have
consistency
across the board and that includes
um what was uh mentioned by councilor
Pollinger with the military and
um other various things
it should remain consistent but not
marriage
unless you got a note yeah
just one one other issue um it's your
inaugural meeting that you had
um I did suggest and also I'll suggest
again that I'd really like to hear what
the youth council's view are on climate
change going forward
what do you think this Council should be
doing and it's a really open-ended
question
a lot of councils don't know what to do
so given that climate change is more
likely to affect your generation than
mine
um the interesting at some stage you can
give some thought to them
yeah no I think that would be good to do
uh yeah we'll definitely look at having
a discussion today thank you councilor
Campbell
uh I mean it was great to hear you
effectively present it like a debate
where you know on the one hand that any
other Hunt is exactly how it debates
normally conducted and that was great
enough because
it comes dirty I think as a matter of
judgment isn't it and I think if uh
probably if I asked each year to argue
the reverse case you probably could do
it quite well
so I I just wonder where you you would
reflect what you want to say about that
I I mean
when exercise and judgment do you see
that there's actually quite a difficult
balance to be struck here and it may be
that may come down in one side or the
other side and it's not necessarily that
means therefore that the the arguments
that you put are wrong it's just that
you know hey look there's a there's a
Ying in a Yang and you end up you try to
judge as best you can either you want to
comment on that yeah it's a hard thing
to argue about
um for either side
um
but
yeah Ryan and I are both Debaters
actually so if that means anything to it
um
yeah I think it's important to have the
discussion though
um even if there are very strong
opinions for both sides
counselor sopathy and councilor
correction thanks Mr
in New Zealand that I don't think the
participation rate at traditional public
meetings should be taken as any
guide on people's actual interest in the
election and that since I first stood
for parliament in 1993
the the drop and attendance at
traditional public meetings has been
extreme and it's not just an
invercargill it's around the country
um the many other ways that people gain
their information about elections and
debate the topics about traditional
public meetings aren't a guide to
whether or not any particular age group
is interested
um in the in a particular election
there's heaps of other ways that people
now get their information
councilor correct oh thank you Council
Ludlow um just a quick question really
and you've spoken before and I think
it's been spoken about by quite a few
people today that you know participation
in those lower ages or age brackets and
particularly anyone under 40
um which for
local government being young if you're
under 40 is would have an overstatement
um but that's what it is that's what the
Benchmark is well if you're 80.
but not wow that's what the benchmarks
Benchmark is for local government is
there anybody under the age of 40
participation or elected is considered
young so unfortunately I fall into that
bracket
um is there anything that you can see
from your standpoint or that youth
council is given consideration to how to
boost that participation because I know
like you see what cancer Campbell said
that it's clear that you two would be
able to clearly exercise that judgment
really well and the people that sit
around youth Council table with you will
probably and that obviously political
activism sort of space or certainly they
pay attention uh what else can we be
doing to get to boost participation and
not just local elections but in politics
in general or
um any kind of council activity in
general
uh good question
um in terms of what council can do I'm
not really sure I think it probably
comes down to a more societal level
um with our culture and how we view
um politics and discussion various
things I guess
typically in general we we think Council
can probably
help out by um you know by doing
effective advertising and just trying to
do their best to engage people but then
again that's easier said than done uh
yeah so just working on engagement but
we it's not yeah in a perfect world it
would be like part of our curriculum I
suppose
um learning about political uh things
but
that's the hard thing to do um with
biases uh in skills
um
to raise awareness around the subject
I don't know guest speakers at schools
[Music]
stuff like that
Reverend cook then Council of Passenger
thank you for actually raising the point
that I was going to make because I think
one of the
reasons why people like me are somewhat
cautious about lowering of the voting
age is because of the death of actual
relevant education within schools that
equip you well to
necessarily
make quality decisions around election
and and I speak as I know because it
didn't really happen for us when we were
young either and by the time I was 21 I
thought I knew and I was sadly deluded
um because I just did not have that
education or life experience to evaluate
what what was being said and heard so I
like the others want to applaud you on
the way that you have presented the
differing opinions that you have on
these things and the engagement that you
are making through youth Council because
I think it will stand you in good stead
going forward so thank you both
councilor pottinger finally thanks to
you it looks yeah just a quick one
obviously we've seen the voting age drop
over the years and say it does get to
16. do you do you see in the future some
disgruntled 14 year olds sitting here in
front of council saying hey now we we
have you dealt with many 14 year olds
what most of them are disgruntled okay
well once once that's not true okay so
yeah where does it stop I think that's
exactly the point counselor pottinger
you know we make reasons for why it
should be 16 but
um you know if 16 why not 14 or why not
Indian why not just you know from the
moment you're born you know there's not
really if we're not sitting it and
keeping it consistent with other things
like 18 uh when you become an adult I
think it you know there's not much
justification why it couldn't be either
either or what can be even less but I'd
assume Levi have
differing to say on that why not 14.
no but um
it depends on how you want to look at it
I guess because yes you can have it in
line with everything else but how
necessary
really is it um
if you wanted to have it online with
something I'd say have it online with
working age
um obviously we have 16 year olds more
likely to work than 14 year olds but
it's still an option for them
um and I think even provided that
we almost could just give 14 year olds
the chance to vote then
that's cool it was a bit of a challenge
this could go on forever yeah thanks for
that so uh thanks for indulging pania
and Leslie can you keep them brief pania
I just want to acknowledge
[Laughter]
in in that direction Leslie I just
wanted to say don't be a don't be afraid
of infinite regression it's the
arguments that count yeah if the
arguments are equally as good for
looking in years to come at the voting
age being lowered to 14 then then
councilors of the future will listen to
those at the time it's the arguments not
the principle of infinite regression
that's the issue here
before we receive the report Ryan you
had a question you wanted to pose yes I
just hit a question regarding uh Council
and counselors use of tech talk
um this question is uh so just in light
of uh recently a month or two ago
parliamentary Services
um banned the use of MPS uh use or
downloading of tick tock uh on the
devices and devices that have uh contact
uh with sensitive information my
question is uh has Council thought about
um this uh this himself or I'm not sure
how many of you have Tech talk but um
well you had a look around the table Rob
probably not but all you need to do is
yeah and probably two of us and one of
us doesn't dance yeah
um the council itself doesn't have a
policy at this point and we we haven't
raised it
um
mayor Clark you didn't have any proposal
to
no no bring forward the Banning of of
tick tock well why not being everything
yeah anything to do with technology oh
yes it was like the last column yeah
um so I guess it's our position is its
individual choice
yeah interestingly Council has a tick
tock account
I was just going to ask because I
thought
on the other hand I wonder how if we
used it on our devices whether we would
get trapped by our new technology that
is just supposed to protect us against
spam and all those sorts of fishing and
all those sorts of things
yeah two completely secret to be fair
we're not that interesting
um
Tom no I was just going to observe the
the blank stairs that you get
um equally from me you know if you'd ask
a question about how we feel about Lut
and declension you'd have to get every
bit as blank a stare I mean I think Tech
talk for me is a fun country
and it's it's actually you know guys at
your age that are and ladies at your age
that are you should be making those kind
of calls because I don't know anything
about technology it's an ironic
description Tom Alex
um I just wanted to I guess assure our
council members that I
I I'd say it's extremely unlikely that
um any of our members around this table
had Tick Tock installed on Council
devices and that's what the
Parliamentary guidance was was that
there it was a blanket ban for tick tock
to be on any parliamentary
issued device
um and so for us the only device that we
have is our iPad some choose to use our
personal devices and I could safely say
that they probably don't have it on
their ideas
um also that just the Assurance of that
we do have
um some cyber security practices in
place
um all of our
um
all of our
sensitive information I suppose you
would say is received through protected
Cloud platforms so
and fair to say actually that none of
the social media platforms or any other
apps are readily downloadable
not that I've tried yet on my Council
device because my other devices have
plenty
from my youthful perspective I think
we're saying
thanks for asking the question though we
appreciate it and and thanks guys for an
invigorating presentation
um I think it all goes well for a good
year with you Council thank you for
putting yourselves forward and
participating and thanks very much for
coming along this afternoon councilor
cricket
I was just youthfuling in Breakers I
thought you were going to move oh yes I
am that we received the report
that all in favor
aye against carried Brian Levi thank you
for coming along thanks very good thank
you councilor Ludlow and Council and
your worship
Council as it takes us back to the
beginning of the agenda we've got the
minutes of the well-being committee uh
held back on March 14 that they've been
confirmed moved Council of partner
secretary councilor cracker any matters
arising
if not put the motion all in favor aye
against carried Eminence of the district
licensing committee meetings
held move that they received secondary
councilor super put that all in favor
aye against
carried no questions
I'm just fascinated what is that
the hutter meeting healthy attitudes
towards alcohol it's a
um
multi-agency group that looks at what
can be done in a coordinated approach to
minimize alcohol risk locally thank you
it's just an acronym I hadn't seen
before
I'm pleased that I could answer it
uh that brings us along to the
[Music]
um
programming framework Richard to come
and take a seat
uh
be assured I'm not going to go through
all 47 pages of this but I will just
give an overview to start with
we're really aware that Council does
some pretty amazing things across our
plethora of community services often
they are done with that I wateringly
focus on community to do the right thing
but we're also aware that sometimes we
don't always leverage our power and our
critical mass across Council and more
coordination would mean greater
efficiency and a greater impact of our
programs and that's the birth of
rangaranga the art of weaving so taking
the expertise the center of excellence
from all over Council and ensuring that
they are meeting together and and
building and leveraging off one another
a couple of points I'll make the
programming framework is around having a
bit of science behind our decisions and
a bit of purposeful intervention in the
community it is not a replacement of
curation so each of our sites will have
specialist curation that they do whether
it be an art gallery a museum or a
theater Etc library that specialist
curation stays intact but it's where we
operate on the fringes where we can see
a program happening in one site might
have greater impact if it's coordinated
with a program at another site
obviously you might say well surely
you're doing this already and we are
doing an element of this but this just
puts an extra safety net to ensure that
we're always using to our Maori lens on
things the Community Development lens an
ectopric lens and a cultural lens on
everything that we do
I will take the reporters read if you
and welcome any questions at the cheers
description
thanks Richard I I guess it's a an
opportunity for a more coordinated
approach and councilor Cricket will
recall that with some of the events
committee funding the questions that we
asked people were what other forms of
Engagement so you're looking at taking a
proactive approach and talking at a at a
higher Staff level at the activities
going on to make sure that we can get
the most out of
what's happening in our spaces
absolutely and look this is starting at
a officer level at a council
organization level but it should set the
the uh work practice if you like our
approach to start to go wider into the
community we're really Keen to do
genuine Partnerships with Community
groups and this is a way of structuring
ourselves to actually grow into the
commercial and Community organizations
that exist in in invercargill to really
do some powerful stuff we're using a
similar approach for the city center
promotions Group which is coordinating
um promotions across the different
players and the commercial world and
it's um
it's working really well so this is just
a way of working that we want to build
on and solidify and give you confidence
that when we make a decision it's not
just something that we've invented Earth
in here that we've done some serious
thinking about ratepayer spend and
ratepayer impact thanks councilor
partinger well thanks Jay look looking
under the heading of financial
implications it says there are no added
costs now I sort of it's sort of like
you sit back when you see that in a
something that's new added and it's a
program
so like even looking at appendix one the
report so that was not done by a
consultant was that done in in-house or
right yeah I see it was Untitled and
unnamed
so there is no there is no extra
software there's no extra you know paper
documentation nothing uh there is extra
paper documentation through Mr but that
is simply to clarify our thinking so as
we're not stepping over sometimes uh we
acknowledge that we've been doing
multiple programs across the city at the
same time and each spending on a bit of
advertising each spending on a bit of
expertise that we could have actually
come together and been more efficient so
no this isn't then and the programming
team is a virtual team it is just about
bringing people together and working
together okay so that takes to the next
question who the coordination obviously
is it done by by a person overseeing it
or is it a whole lot of well-oiled cogs
just miraculously working
uh through Mr the second idea of the
well-oiled miraculous cogs would it
would be an aspirational thought uh we
already get together and we do do this
at a certain scale so for example the
most common
um way of working is for example School
holiday programs and all the
representatives for now Community are
now um Leisure and Rec group get
together already and do that so this is
just about coordination in meetings it's
not uh added extra it's making sure that
what we're doing we're doing it well no
I guess my question was there must be to
coordinate you often need a chair or
someone someone to drive
yeah so uh we have had commitment from
parts of council to step up to that sort
of but remember we're all part of it
this is about the Leisure and wreck
response at this point in time and
therefore we are already meeting
regularly and working together
cooperatively in the one Council
approach
Reverend cook then Council of Germany
killer Richard
example would be
that could be across everything that the
council does all of their business not
just Leisure and Rec so that's
uh and we'll all in approach
um but the one thing that I did notice
in absence of was the mention of
tahinaki the Civic Council building
itself because whilst you do promotional
activities for the Civic Theater within
here
um this would actually be a place where
we could be doing other
um promotion of haywalker tour promotion
of something at the library or those
sorts of things so I just noticed its
absence and thought I'd draw it to your
attention that I thought that
this building could usefully be part of
that
process even though it's not part of
leisure and Rec to respond to that
through you Mr chair you're absolutely
right
um I've tried to stick to my mandate and
stay within my for once stay within my
department
um but if proof of concept works and
this is something that Council sees
value for and sees the result uh
obviously we'd love to see it expand
throughout the rest of council and then
as I say into that those Community
Partnerships as well even forbid I
should lead you astray Richard Council
of Germany then councilor swiper yeah
thanks chair just um page two you've
identified some areas and you know there
may be more diploma across wide area
just wondered about the bluff community
and also see our city with the any sort
of areas or places there that were given
consideration that maybe on the initial
phase three minutes year again
um we've just kept this tight to Leisure
and Rec and we actually don't have a
huge presence in love we do have the
library uh obviously out there and
Community Partnership with the Paul Etc
uh again we were just trying to make
sure that we're not uh going too big too
quick but certainly we want to take
consideration you know absolutely
counselor soap I think councilor
corrector thanks Gia um I'll just say
end the Maritime Museum yeah
that wasn't my main point look I just
wanted to say
um
anything that is going to be more
collaborative is great and coming coming
from a background in this particular
area I can see the the um winds in this
I was initially a little bit worried
that there might be some watering down
no curatorial
issues but having read all 47 pages I
can clearly see that that is
far away from being the intention and
I'm I'm
comfortable with that and I I think it
will be a good collaboration because I
think we've all noticed that there has
been sometimes
when some programs have overlapped in
ways that
probably didn't need to happen or that
there were
a couple of programs running at the same
time we're a bit more collaboration
would have made a big difference to turn
out and delivery so
um
good to see it at this point
cancel forward to the reports
um thank you councilor Ludlow um my
question is around the priority gaps and
who determines them they've gotten a
paragraph there that there's data that
will likely identify obvious areas for
programming intervention but if I look
at things like you know Splash Palace or
the library we collect phenomenal
amounts of demographic data like if it's
either an adult or a child but we have
no way of knowing if they're male female
if they're disabled if they're not you
know like so how is it is it all going
to be anecdotal from the the managers of
the facility I just would really like to
see it being a bit more data driven if
it's all in the project framework in
that manner through Mr chair absolutely
we acknowledged early on that that's one
of our biggest gaps is data hard hard
fast data the criteria in terms of how
we've split it up is based on the census
parameters that they have so as at least
we can see what uh what the census
provides us but yeah in terms of
surveying our stuff we we've got an
ongoing conversation about how we
actually get their Intel and that's why
when we came to the
prioritization Matrix and those
different things I've tried to mix what
is hard and fast absolute science and
what is that anecdotal thing because we
are a human based business and there
will always be an element of I think
there's something missing I think uh
going forward something we've had a lot
of conversation about is we measure the
people who engage with Council one thing
we don't do very well because it's very
difficult is measuring those who are
disengaged or unengaged who don't we
know is out there not using our service
and that is you know they've been
conversations around perhaps doing
intercept surveys at places like a
supermarket or somewhere that has a high
population that doesn't necessarily a
user in asking you know are you using
the service what are you doing and that
would form some of those priority uh
priorities also our community engagement
processes or even from this Council
there's enough information and touch
points actually build a good picture but
it's not science and I need to sort of
stress that there is no mathematical way
to really pinpoint it will always have
an element of human interpretation and
that's why I've stressed through the
document it's not a hand fast Rule and
we're not you know we we want to do this
so we can trial so we can error so we
can pile it and that means sometimes
we'll get it wrong or inaccurate but
this will at least mean that prior to
making those decisions we've gone
through a process
okay
councilor Boyle
very much it's great to see this is the
way we
show if you do are able to collect data
to consider what what part of the city
or Bluff or where the people are using
it you know because it's the perception
that there are some people South South
invercargill who don't use these events
they're only used by people who who have
easy access and it would be really
useful for us as you can to consider
that as well
thank you any further questions
counselors
councilor Campbell
I I must say that
I mean it's good stuff it seemed to me
an extremely complicated document to try
to read and for anybody who's you know
started for Scratch and and reading it
voluntarily rather than compulsively is
always you know I wondered who father
would get and I I wonder if it could be
simplified actually I mean it seems to
me to be a relatively straightforward
system it's good system relatively
straightforward the challenge would be I
think to turn into two or three pages uh
you know
three mystery I do have a confession to
make at this point uh and that's was
when I was writing this document and
compiling the data it was meant to be an
internal document
um as we were going through we realized
that yes this will help staff who are
quite familiar with programming and it
won't it's not quite so daunting but we
realized that there was value in sharing
it with elected members because often we
do this stuff invisible and we thought
but I take your point it's not an easy
read
somebody tier 2 moves the two
recommendations
Council of Germany Reverend cook thank
you put that all in favor
thank you Richard thank you and I just
want to point out I have coordinated my
shoes and my tie to the cover report and
I think this is an expectation that
should go on for all officers
but but did you consult with your
workmates oh we had a whole programming
team at Great expense
that's all Details page 48. thank you
very much
good work councilors uh item 8 on the
agenda is the Queen's Park land
reclassification but staff have
requested that the paper is not reviewed
today and is deferred until a later date
so I'm happy to let that happen
um when it becomes relevant it doesn't
need to be enacted yet so that moves us
on to the activities reports
who's kicking that off I'll kick it off
of Jonathan and Jay might wander up to
the front table so that they can talk to
their part of it
um just a couple of points in regards to
legal and Recreation it does follow it
to agree on to what Richard was talking
about around our recovery around our
programming and services a lot of the
data that you've got on this activity
report again reflects our post covered
recovery as as a service area
and a lot of that in part is just
because the country is recovering but
it's also because of the hard work of a
lot of people around making programs
that better fit the needs of our
community and getting more out into our
community on a more regular basis so I
just I think that should be community
and recognize that this is not just an
accident that we are working really hard
again the cafe result to the splash
Palace do speak to the amount of effort
we're putting in to make sure we're
providing the right service at the right
time and
um again because we are succeeding
people are buying more and it's great
for our business
I'd also probably want to note just in
regards you have picked up around
Queen's Park and the potential for
future tree removal
now this is in line with our
requirements
um to support the air traffic and the
ear path
and we have worked with the airport and
prioritizing where these trees are and
unfortunately we've got individual trees
but because of the way our trees work
and winds that we will be looking at a
program of tree removal that takes out
groups of trees because we have to also
provide a really healthy and safe
environment for our users on a daily
basis we'll be doing as much as we can
to minimize that and we'll communicate
the program once we've got it through
within the next couple of months as to
where this will happen and when and
certainly want to make sure that
everyone in the community is rest
assured that whatever we remove we will
be replanting very quickly and and you
will have seen that along Calvin Street
and how we've removed a stand of trees
and replaced it almost immediately with
more trees they will take some time time
to grow but if you've ever seen a
historic photo of Queen's Park it did
not always have big trees and so we'll
be looking forward to that program
I'm happy to pass over to Joe and
Jonathan to with a quick summary then we
can take questions
so our numbers are pretty consistent
from last year to this year heading
through our Civic administration
building and also Bluff the only other
point that I wanted to add is that the
education around the parking kiosks
that's going out in our rates notices
this month and also the library staff
have been trained and they're going to
support us in any education that's
required for the community around that
um so I'll take my parts of the report
as read uh probably the only significant
update is just regarding the parking
which we discussed at last well-being
committee meeting
um to speak to Joe's Point uh a lot of
it seem does seem to be around education
but also we've identified that
uh there's a potential for
um reviewing the activity as a whole
within the activity management plans for
how we actually approach parking
compliance with what we're trying to
achieve
so thank you questions counselors
councilor Campbell
I wonder if you could comment a little
bit more about the flight pass issue
when you remove trees particular order
trees as you know it will result in
comment which is not all very
um good
um when a airplane passes over the trees
in Queen's Park it's about a thousand
feet just by judgment we don't have many
trees at a thousand feet high I would
think the highest would be 50 feet or
something so I mean
it sort of sounds like it's a excuse
rather than a reason
um I mean if I was explaining it to
somebody white as we've got to take out
that standard trees
um if I said well it's because of the
flight pass I think they would sit in me
well you know that seems like an excuse
rather than the reason so I just wonder
if you could explain a little bit more
how the height of your tree and that
location affects an airplane a thousand
feet up
well I I guess touching on that page 67
gives a summary from our district plan
requirements of what sets out the
minimum requirements and the civil
aviation Authority
set the regulations in regards to flight
paths for each of the airports around
the country and so what we're really
doing is working towards more of a
compliance with our own District plan
and with the CIA requirements for that
flight path and being a pilot I
understand exactly what you're saying
however our trees are into that ear Zone
and so the airport have requested that
we remove those 43 odd trees and we'll
be prioritizing that over the next two
years based on
I guess in terms of height but also
based on location and how we best
achieve that and also maintain the
amenity value of the park too because we
do recognize it as a very fine balancing
act so the key Point what you just said
and I'm sorry if it's in the report and
I've just never quite picked up on it
we're removing these trees at the
specific request of the airport okay
thank you foreign
Boyle I'd just like to acknowledge the
um the work that you've done with the
parking meters and I'm just going to
give you an example I was with Joe
giving out some gifts on Friday and
there was a woman
um an area who was having trouble with a
parking meter which I was outstanding
she explained
um to her about the app how it worked
and whatever else even gave her um her
number to contact her if she needed more
so if that's the kind of service that
you're doing that's excellent
thank you for the feedback
any other questions Reverend cook oh I
had a comment as well and it's very
similar to Trisha's
um I came into the building one day and
somebody was struggling outside
um as a non-user of parking meters for
an obvious reason
um I asked one of the concert staff to
help and they were very prompt and very
you know and I appreciate
that they do go beyond the extra mile
for
um the people who use the facilities
around here I think it's important I
wish I actually knew how to do it myself
but not having the need
it's just something I don't need to
learn I don't think
thank you I'll give them the feedback
hey Clark
just a totally separate issue for Steve
um I get a lot of questions from people
about the eye center that used to be in
the old Museum that doesn't seem to be
anywhere now
people from outside the city that come
in I mean recently had a look at the one
in Wellington which is quite large space
probably as big as this chamber three or
four star heaps of people in there
wanting that physical contact I know
we've had the debate about
you can do it all online but it seems to
me there's still a good level of people
that are older I guess not familiar with
tech or
um people that are foreigners that might
be tourists here that feel more
comfortable with actually going running
up to somebody and getting some
pamphlets about it so
I didn't have the answer for people to
keep asking me you know what's up
eyesight as a franchise and not a cheap
one yeah there are other options that we
could look at to provide that similar
service for those who prefer the
brochures and the one-on-one personal
contact but eyesight itself I think once
the museum closed we had a temporary one
and and walked in place yeah
um then tourism stopped uh so there was
no point in continuing to pay to be part
of a franchise and the franchise from
memory Steve
struggles to make a profit of most
venues apart from heavy tourist centers
I probably couldn't make a statement
definitively on that point but I think
each location varies based on where you
place them what role they are and
certainly as you know as part of our
looking at what the future Museum looks
like
we are reaching out to our friends in
the department of conservation
um who also have the information centers
as part of their service and we're
working with them on what that might
look like in other cable so I'd be happy
to bring back further advice to this
meeting
once we've had that conversation with
him yeah I think with the tourism doors
being open now
um and it would be helpful to know
whether we're going down that track of
yeah the last one was very well received
if Thomas and there were heaps of people
in there looking at tourism options and
with sitting with Jeff Thompson and the
ilt also wanting to get into this area
might be quite helpful to give some
thought to that I guess Joe
Bluff service center and also concierge
downstairs we do get requests for
information and we are you know always
on the internet Etc and helping people
with the information that they need so
we are able to supply some of it as
people come in and particularly Bluff
they're very busy in that space yeah
thank you
so no further questions would somebody
like to move the reports received
Council of Boyle and Campbell put that
all in favor against
Carrie that brings us to the end of the
public session I'll now move that we go
into committee for the reasons as
outlined on the agenda but uh if we can
allow Ricky panata and Jana Davis from
totapa Tani to remain for an item that
comes up first and
public excluded public forum
I'll move in that direction if it's a
secondary Council of Dermody thank you
but they're all in favor all right
against carried uh the live stream for
this will end and we